ah this is our receptionist pam pam pam
pam
pam beazley uh pam has been with us um
for forever right pam
well i don't know if you think she's
cute now you should have seen her a
couple of years ago all right all right
what
all right everybody oh my god pam
those make you look so ugly um pam in
order to get hotter you take glasses off
you're moving in the wrong direction
i don't have i drive back i can't even
hear you it's just noise coming out of
an ugly scientist
okay
do you want me to stop dating your mom
is that how we're gonna get past this
cause i will
yes well that is not gonna happen then
why'd you even offer because i assumed
that you want me to be happy because i
want you to be happy michael let me make
this very easy for you i could give it
about your happiness stop dating my
mother
you know what i'm gonna start dating her
even harder what's that supposed to mean
you know what it means
i think i finally realized how you must
be failing
we are both the victims of broken
engagements
you were never really engaged i was in
that
marriage arena though
yeah yeah
well
i kind of thought something would happen
tonight too
so like
so alike
what are you doing what are you doing
i'm rejecting your kiss i didn't
could i have a ride home
if you sit in the back
these are not my shoes
this is just like the show taxicab
confessions you say one more word i'm
stopping the car
hey hey oh my god what are you doing you
said come in no i didn't just oh my god
please
so i closed the door but the image of
his
dangling participle
still burned in my eyes i can imagine
come in
may i enter the room yes or come in
see how i did that
that's the way you should enter a room
you knock and then you wait for the all
clear you couldn't have taken off all
your clothes in the men's room yes but i
have an office so why would i do that on
average how many hours a day do you
spend naked in your office just ballpark
european offices are naked all the time
they're so not besides my suretail
covered most of it so i didn't see where
it started i saw where it ended gross
that's not gross it is a human body what
is your problem
pam you're an artist right think of me
as one of your models
okay you know what i don't want this to
detract from what we really need to be
thinking about today it's not fair to
people with rabies
and that's
the point
right
okay let's go have some fun all right
they say if you're nervous around
someone you should picture them naked
i do not recommend this strategy
try picturing them with more clothes on
or a funny coat i just want to take a
minute to talk to you all about
something very serious once every hour
someone is involved in an internet scam
that man is michael scott
he's supporting about 20 nigerian
princesses hey you know what
forgive me for caring right
well you know michael is a great
delegator
he never does any work himself ever
[Laughter]
and one time i walked in on him naked
and his thing is so small
how small is it if it were an ipod it
would be a shuffle
just go along with it okay all right
just follow my lead don't pimp me all
right come in
so uh corporate just said that i don't
want to oh thank you pam pam can you
come in here for a sec
just have a seat i was gonna call you in
anyway um
you know ryan
um as you know
there is going to be downsizing and uh
you have made my life
so much easier
in that i am going to have to let you go
first
what why
why well theft
and stealing
stealing
um
what am i supposed to have stolen
post-it notes
post-it notes yeah okay what are those
worth like 50 cents 50 cents yeah you
steal a thousand post-it notes at 50
cents a piece and you know you've made a
profit
margin you know go
run us out of business pam
are you serious
yeah i am
um
i can't believe this i mean i've never
even stolen as much as a paper clip and
now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
we're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh i just clean out
your desk i'm sorry
you've been
ex-punk surprise it's a joke we were
joking around
let's see
okay he was in on it he was my
accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of kind of giving him the
feel of the place
so
you
god you were we totally got you're a
jerk
i don't know about that
the last pickup for overnight deliveries
is at seven so you need to have them
signed by then
or much earlier chillax pam stop pam
messing
that's pretty good um actually i'm
sending ryan on a top secret mission
tell her what it is
updating emergency contacts
well is that really a priority is it a
priority oh i don't know um what if
there's a tornado pam people's legs are
crushed under rubble please would you be
so kind as to call my wife no i can't
because we don't have any emergency
contact information because pam said it
wasn't a priority think think with your
head pam okay well she walks out i have
a way to make scranton a better place
you could leave it
okay i'm out of here see you later guys
okay oh no here's an idea conservation i
love it conservation let's start by
conserving our time and stop having
these stupid meetings
no more meetings no more meetings no
more meetings no more meetings okay so
what we do
is we drive all day
and we stay in hotels together like
separate rooms well that goes without
saying i'm gonna say it anyway hey look
at what you're wearing again pam
have you ever seen a magician's
assistant that's
this is a new cardigan kind of
black
maybe you could tie it around your waist
or
lose the shirt underneath or something
no
all right
you have to keep your hands down i know
okay
all right
oh god michael you have to put your
hands down put your hands in your pocket
okay
pam pam
i'm really sorry i'm sorry what are you
sorry for so many things i don't know
it's hard to choose how about for dating
my mom
maybe that's dumping her on her birthday
yes
okay just
don't ever date a member of my family
again
okay i promise
for the record your mom came on to me
holy crap
are you okay no
you're okay
feel better
no you were right
wait why are you limping i don't know
let's get some raw meat on that face
i've got a chicken in the freezer
upstairs
you know what pam if in 10 years
i haven't had a baby and you haven't had
a baby no michael
20 years no
michael 30.
sure
it's a deal
you